dj khaled and Justin Bieber are back and
calda wants to sing their new collab
Bieber's wedding
happy Friday babes this is the daily
Denny and what a week it's been huh
mercury may be in retrograde right now
but it's nothing but positive vibes here
because it is new music Friday
here are three certified bops according
to meet for your weekend DJ Khaled is
back with another one reuniting him with
Justin Bieber
huevo and chance the rapper following
their smash hit I'm the one this time
the all-star team is looking to
shattered records again with their new
smash no brainer of calots upcoming
album father of assad and these guys
proved that if it ain't broke don't
[Music]
think khaled of course has been busy
hyping up the new track for weeks just
ask our own Katie crouch who caught up
with the mega producer at the for season
2 finale taping it's here right now I'm
saying it's Friday it's here Khaled
Bieber quavo chance the rapper it's a
no-brainer
point do you just call them up do you
text them how do you get him how do you
get them involved well FaceTime Bieber
and I was like yo I don't even give him
a chance to say hi he picked up the
FaceTime seob but check this I know I
ain't supposed to be calling you right
now and say let's make another record
together cuz we made one last year debut
number one on the Hot 100 by the way um
and I was like you're people but what's
wrong with doing it again we're gonna
see you guys perform this song at the
wedding I mean that would be a
no-brainer
um saying so your Bieber let's make it
happen let's perform no-brainer at your
wedding with you performing in it you're
saying I'd be crazy right the epic
that'd be a no-brainer another one well
it is a hot one
and speaking of Madame Tussauds in
Orlando just debuted a shirtless version
of Justin's wax figure which by the way
has been updated to include his latest
tattoos so get out of ladies you have a
limited time before you can get up close
and personal with Justin before he's
officially off the market
all right well that's a sight for sore
eyes and I've got another track for your
ears producer RL Graham dropped his
latest single light me up between dream
team Miguel and Julia Michaels now the
duo sing about supporting each other
through hard times which I feel like is
totally contradictory because this song
slaps
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna continue with the bangers
because you know French DJ David Guetta
is no stranger to collabing with pop
music sirens from SIA to Kelly Rowland
he knows how to pick them and he's done
it again with singer Ann Marie who
dazzles on their new single don't leave
me alone
[Music]
is it too late to include this as an
entry for song of the summer you tell me
because I can't get out of my head
alright well guys that's it for today
short and sweet we'll be back on Monday
with more daily denne until then make
sure you're following us here on
Facebook watch and following us on ET
online.com for all the latest now have a
good weekend I know I will